hey guys Ryan right here I gotta leave
for work in a few minutes but I'm a big
David Fincher fan I like new and
improved Ben Affleck so there's a
trailer out for a gone girl funny fact
Ben Affleck directing a movie called
Gone Baby Gone and now we starring gone
girl and after he got cast as Batman all
the respect he earned back was gone
we all know my wife Amy Elliott Dunne
disappeared three days ago she may be I
don't like that actress I think she
sucks a trace of pleasure or regret
maybe my treasure he gets the best DB's
man after him
she may be the Sun let's Ellis's maybe
the chill at all to equals maybe a
hundred different things o Gomorrah so
sexy
Ruby Peter
Oh
I don't think that was Kmart
me I'll take a look
and make em on my suit
at Tyler Perry
this baby's going to be really
depressing I did not kill my wife I am
NOT a murderer
they just ruined that she's officially
dead
that looks intense I love David
Fincher's movies I mean he's good at all
these crime type of films social network
was awesome everyone knows that yeah man
[ __ ] Fight Club panic room 7 Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo he knows how to
make [ __ ] dark intense character
driven movies and Ben Affleck I'm hoping
gives a solid performance he's been
doing a great job these past few years
so I'm hoping he does rock it and you
know he really needs this movie to do
well because he's [ __ ] Batman and no
one's happy about that anyway if you
guys are new to the channel subscribe I
can't think of another rhyme that kind
of sounded like I was rhyming I don't
know why I keep doing videos when the
battery's about the dot but here we go
some shoutouts
Ryan o or Li I like your name Ryan no or
Li I like your name Ryan sexy name we
should compare penis sizes J Google uh
he's fairly new to the channel wants a
shout out so hey new buddy
welcome to the family he has ever been
to a network marketing company where
they all show welcome to the family it's
creepy as [ __ ]
Ruby Rock five five five Chinese man
from Cigna pork or woman forgot male or
female you're awesome
anyone who's not from the states
subscribes to the channel thank you
you're awesome and if you are from the
states
Thank You brother or sister and one of
you sisters will be my girlfriend one
day that sounds really weird you're
really you up for some dating advice can
you guys give me some dating advice
below on how to even approach a girl
there's one subscriber named Michelle
Fernandes I keep talking about her she's
really cute ah as far as you commenting
Michelle I'm gonna keep talking about
you she lives in Florida that's very far
away but you know Michelle we could do
long-distance it would be really nice
I'm in love with you Michelle branded I
don't know you at all but you're into
movies and that's all that counts cuz I
don't meet a lot of girls who are into
movies it's actually kind of annoying
why don't you wouldn't go of warned yeah
but seriously if you lived in California
would you want to go on a date with me I
mean that I can only imagine what it's
like being on your enemies and it must
be really creepy